what we really want
is to not just spend time with the other
person or have things in common or have
sex with them or be romantic with them
or pick whatever you want or even do
nice things for them
we want to be the same being
we want to be
fused together he says if if have faced
us you know the God you know who like
did all this kind of stuff the god of
Smith I suppose we'd say the god of
Technology were to show up and say do
you think you'd like for me to take you
to and like weld you into one being
they'd be like that was it that's what
we wanted
that's what we've been seeking out so
all of our other desires all of our
other ways of loving are just sort of
Shadows of something that's for us
unattainable